our next application for
multi-objective least squares is
estimation and inversion i mean
that's a it's a huge field i'll say a
little bit about it you could take
entire courses on nothing but this but
we'll say a little bit about it now
so your model is this you have a
so-called measurement model
and here you have an an n vector x
um and that's the parameters that you
want to estimate that that's what you
want to ask
and you don't have a way to directly
measure them okay so
uh could be that x is going to be
the density of voxels uh
under the ground under the you know you
don't want to drill a well a test well
to actually measure it
okay y is going to be a vector of
measurements that we take
right so these could be measurements
that we take above ground for example
then what we're going to do is we're
going to say that the model
looks like this it's y equals ax plus
v um v is the vector
right so sorry it's a vector of noise
let's say let's see or disturbances or
errors or however you want to think of
it so here y equals ax is a linear model
now a
comes from you know either physics
first principles all sorts of stuff
right but a a represents the mapping
from
the parameters you are interested in
measuring or estimating
and how they map into the things that
you actually really measured that's why
and v is sort of is sometimes called the
measurement error something like that
okay uh all right so that's the idea um
and you know
you know in in estimation you would know
a
uh that describes your system um and you
would
observe y and your goal is to guess
x okay um now
one interesting thing here is you know
when you if you know why
um and you know uh if you know why you
know
a um if you make any guess x you can
look at y
equals ax and you're you're basically
guessing what v
is at that point right so so v is y
minus
ax and in basically squares estimation
it goes like this
we will simply assume that this noise
vector is small
so you know that that's what it means
it's like i took these measurements
i took 250 measurements of temperature
um
yeah they're all you know i don't think
any of these temperature measurement is
exactly correct but they're all probably
within you know
0.1 degrees c or something like that so
this kind of fits the idea that
these are the measurements are good but
they're not perfect by any means
okay um and so here's least squares
estimation
you are going to guess x by minimizing
uh norm uh ax minus y
now let's note what that is ax is what
our model
says y would be without noise
um y is what we actually observed and so
this says
please choose me an x for which the our
model
would model output would match as
closely as possible what we actually
measured so that's a
that's that's least squares uh
estimation and
it's completely normal and makes makes
perfect uh perfect sense
um i should also add that this vector is
minus v
so another way to say it is please
choose an
x so that given the noise we observe
that tells you what v
is and that's the measurement noise and
you say please give me an x for which we
have to imagine that the measurement
noise
is very small as small as possible so
that's least squares
least squares estimation okay
now um sometimes when people do this in
fact
very frequently when people do this they
had regularization
and that's called either regularized
estimation sometimes called regularized
inversion
something like that and the way that
works
is you simply factor in to the problem
you solve to guess
x prior information about x and that
prior could be things like this
you think well i don't think x should be
too large that's that's what i think
um or i think x should be smooth
something like that so and you can have
any so all sorts of priors here
right um now in other courses you would
study priors like i think x has to be
non-negative or x is betw the answers of
x are between 0 and 1.
we can't handle that in this course but
you'll see other courses where
priors like that can actually be handled
but not in this course and nevertheless
what we're going to talk about here is
is good enough
for many many applications so let's see
um now these are expressed
these prior the prior information about
x is expressed
uh using things like uh norm x squared
that that
that mathematically expresses the prior
that x is small
and that's got a name it's called
ticking off regularization
and that's based on uh this is named for
a
russian mathematician ticking off
another one would be j2 equals dx where
d
is some kind of difference operator for
example if x is a time
series that you're trying to guess but
it could well if it's a time series
you're trying to guess
dx is the matrix the difference matrix
and so dx is the differences
and it says you would like to guess an x
which is smoothly varying and that would
be that would be this
this use um you'd use j2 here
then you'll minimize j1 plus lambda j2
and then there's the question of what
value of lambda do you choose and
uh so i'll be honest in most in many
applications it's just done
it's ad hoc and you adjust lambda until
you like the results
i mean it visually it makes sense or you
go find an expert in the field and you'd
say
hey i'm estimating this does this look
cool does this look is this kind of what
you'd expect to see
and when the expert says yes then that
means you've got lambda right
so uh okay now
the the uh x x hat the
the the one that minimizes uh j1 plus
lambda j2
that's a function of lambda and so we're
going to denote that as x hat of lambda
and that's called the regularization
path it's like a curve
which where you change the parameter
lambda and
this this point in our n
in this n vector moves around along a
curve and that's called the
regularization path
path or curve and
now this and very interesting things
happen when you look at this when you
when you minimize this and taken off
regularization for example
you end up with a getting stacked on top
of
a a multiple squared lambda actually
times i
the identity and the result is that even
a
even when a has dependent columns um
the the the taken off regularized
inversion
least squares problem is is well um it
makes sense right it's got
independent columns so it's very
interesting so it means you can actually
do
invert quote inversion even when
you have fewer measurements then you
have
parameters you want to estimate that
happens when a is wide here
that's called a wide system
okay so we'll look at a specific example
now it's very simple
and you can see a lot of other there's a
lot of other examples but we'll look at
this one
so here x is representing an image so
that means it's in some order it's the
the voxels uh and it's a it's a
monochrome
uh image grayscale so uh in some order
i maybe maybe it's i go across the rows
and i list those but so x is an image
it's probably not
not small it's maybe like i don't know
at least 10 000 or maybe 100 000 million
10 million high okay then the matrix a
is a blurring operator
and we've seen that that's it could be
like a convolution that's a very simple
model
of how some for example optical systems
work
is that you convolve what you really see
in the image plane
to get what you actually observe or
measure in your
microscope or camera okay so
then you can think of y equals ax plus v
as a blurred
noisy image we'll see examples of it
pretty soon
least squares d blurring says this it
says
i'm going to give you y that's that's
the blurred image and it says
i'm going to choose an image x
that uh this first term says ax
is actually what the image would be if
there were no noise
um and so you say the first thing i want
is i want to choose x so that
what the image would be without noise uh
is
at least close to what i actually
observed so that's that's the first term
the second term is regularization it's
the dirichlet
energy dirichlet energy is in this case
for the case of an image
it's actually a sum of two norm squareds
and these are these are gigantic
matrices
uh super sparse by the way dv and dh
for vertical and horizontal and these
give you the horizontal and vertical
differences uh of uh for an image um
and so these are you know this is this
is stuff
this is really big uh but the idea is we
can solve it it's also super sparse by
the way
um and here what this says
is you know please get me an x that
under my image
blurring model would have produced what
i saw close enough
or close um but also i want x to be
smooth
why because i might know ahead of time x
is smooth okay so that's the
that that's what this would be and then
we would uh we would turn
we'd turn lambda and until we like what
we see
that's one option is you you do this and
you turn lambda until you look at the
output and say i don't i like it i don't
like it something like that
um there are more principled ways to
choose lambda
for example you could have some
experimental setup where
you you know the image exactly you
actually know what x is
and then you could judge your uh you
could choose
lambda by trying under these careful you
know
experiments you know doing this and
seeing how close
x is to the true x um so that would
actually be a
very reasonable way to choose lambda
so we'll do an example it's a footprint
on the moon
so here is on the left you see the
blurry
noisy image so that's that's the
that's the blurry noisy image
and here's what it looks like and we i
chose blend equals 0.007 because
i don't know to my eye it looked the
best but you know again
you could do this many many other ways
um and actually if you look closely at
them you'll see it actually did
something it actually sharpened
it sharpened up the edges pretty well uh
i mean it's it's actually like
you can see visible d blurring oh and
this would be calling this would be
called
you might call this uh least squares d
blurring d blurring means to undo the
effects of this blur
uh in some optical system okay
now i'll show you the regularization
path or i should say i'll show you like
four points on it so
if i take lambda equals 10 to the minus
six um you know that basically says
if you go back to the problem here it
basically says don't worry about this
term
and it says you know just get me
something that through my forward
model oh i should say sometimes it's
called the forward model
would would produce what i actually the
image i actually saw
and it says this says the fact that land
is 10 to minus 6 says you know what
don't worry about don't worry about x
being smooth too much
and sure enough look at this it's all
it's not smooth at all
actually the good news is it's pretty
sharp bad news is it's
it's not smooth at all okay here is
lambda equals 10 to the minus four and
you can see by cranking up
the parameter the parameter that control
that scales the regularization
which is the smoothness you can see it's
still
pretty sharp but it's getting smoother
so that and again that makes sense um oh
um i should point out
that the lambdas are varying over very
wide range
um this is very common in in
multi-objective least squares it's very
common that the lambdas that the weights
um weight or weights vary over a wide
range and it's usually logarithmically
spaced
people have found that that's simply
just works better
okay um here you go this is increasing
lambda this is ten to the minus two
and the good news is you don't see any
more of that little speckle stuff
anymore
uh but it's still actually pretty i
think it's i would have to say it's
yeah okay it's definitely it is
definitely better than the original blur
damage so it so you're still getting
some blurry
some d blurring at ten to the minus two
okay
and then here it is with lambda equals
one um
and now you can see what's happened now
is i'm putting too much emphasis
on the reconstructed image being smooth
and so
it's kind of some i'm losing some of the
details of the edges and things like
that and so that would give you
this thing here and if i went to land
equals 100 what do you imagine it would
look like
well i can tell you if you go to lambda
equals 100 i don't have it here but if
you go to land people's 100
it would just be like a kind of a gray
white blob
it'd be so smooth that you might not
even be able to detect it as
a footprint so okay
um another example of this oh going well
and a a very very common widespread
is tomography so so the idea in
tomography
uh is that so x represents the values of
of some quantity in some region of
interest um and these are called uh
voxels if it's in three dimensions and
pixels if it's in two
right so uh i'll show you an example is
here's some
region here and i have set it up as a
an array of five by five um
five by five pixels because this is in
two dimensions so we call these pixels
and the idea is i'm going to approximate
the value of something as sort of
constant in each of these
in each of these boxes right by the way
people would not do this with five by
five i mean they would be more like a
hundred by hundred
or a thousand by thousand or something
like that so but this is just to
illustrate how it works
and then to give x as a vector i might
for example do the row
uh row i'd give you the first row second
and so on so
this would be x25 so if i give you
a a 25 vector then that corresponds to a
you know a a a set of a field of bunch
of values in this region
okay now in tomography the basic idea is
that you can't go in and measure stuff
maybe you can but you don't want to
because that's invasive um
but what you do have is you have uh
integrals along lines through the region
so that's that's the typical thing and
so here's here's here's a line
that goes through this region and um
what it is is what i get here is
precisely
this i get uh the length
of that line uh times the value of this
x that's x that's probably 11 and so
that is probably
16 x 16. if i did if i did my index
arithmetic correctly
um that's x 17 and you can see that it
takes a you know that's the coefficient
so
it's the length of the line here so you
can see actually
that each row we're going to write that
this way that y
i is is well it's sum i
equals 1 and a aij xj aij is the length
of the intersection of the line measured
with voxel j
so that's that's the that's the picture
here um you can see that this is
actually kind of sparse like so for
example in this particular example
that line goes through one two three
four five
six seven it goes through seven of our
pixels we have 25 pixels
so that means that 18 18 entries of
the row of a corresponding to this
measurement
are zero so so this is very typical in
tomography is that sometimes it's
you know things are uh the the so-called
measurement matrix
that's what a is um is the sparse okay
now the goal here is to do the following
is is given a bunch of values of y
and these are measures of these line
integrals the goal
is to guess x right and so
um you know classic example would be
you know a cat scan or something where
i would um i would send x-rays through
and an x-ray just
shoots right through and uh if you
transform the actual variables like the
log of the intensity correctly
then what you'll find out is that this
model is pretty pretty accurate right if
it's
if it's a little tiny beam but it looks
something like that
and the idea is from from seeing
the integral along different lines we
can actually kind of guess
what x is right so okay
so least squares tomographic
reconstruction goes like this
the primary objective is something like
that a is our measurement model
it tells us specifically how
x would map to y right and so
x is the values of at the pixels or
voxels
and why is the met the the observed line
integrals
um through the whatever through the
through the medium
now we add to this regularization and
they they would capture prior
information about x um for example it
could be that x is small
or it could be that it's the it's smooth
in which case we'd use the dirichlet
energy
and we might even do that this way but
we might use
we would we would minimize then a x
minus y squared that's our primary
objective
our secondary objective fact we could
have two we could make it three we could
have this something like this
um might look like that sorry
that's what i meant to do these are not
subscripts or super ships there okay
and here omega is and lambda are
positive
and they are parameters or some people
would call them hyper parameters
that you tune uh to make this work well
now when you make lambda big and x is
going to be small
if you make omega big x is going to be
smooth for example
and if you make both small you're you're
going to fit uh you're going to fit the
what you actually observed your actual
line integral measurements
uh well so that's that's kind of the
picture
so we'll do an example uh here's an
example and it'll give you a rough idea
of
you know what this what this does okay
so uh
we have 4 000 line integrals that we're
going to take
and the way we're going to do it is uh
there are a whole bunch of points we
have 100 points
here so they're spaced at um maybe
3.6 degrees apart from each other so we
we have those those points
and then from each point we spray out 40
lines
uh equally uh you know equally spaced in
angle okay so these are the this is just
showing you i'm showing you maybe 80
of the different line integrals right so
so these are
these just lines that pass through our
object now our object
our region of interest is this square in
the middle here
okay um so i get a lot of integrals
um well like it's worth that i get 4000
lined integrals right
and you know we could say i mean some of
this is kind of obvious right that if a
line integral
turns out to be small it means it didn't
go through very much
the x values it passed through were
pretty small um
if it's large it means it had to pass
through some some part
where uh where there was actually like a
high value
and so so okay so um
then we're going to do is we're going to
take this region of interest to square
make it 100 by 100 pixels so we have 10
000 pixels here um and then we're going
to put
this this image or not this thing this
object
and into this tomographic system right
so
it's actually kind of interesting i mean
remember you know you're getting 4 000
numbers
and your job is
to basically figure out what is in that
box just by looking at the integrals to
go through it um
yeah by the way no one i mean no no
human being can do that i mean
that's kind of obvious right um but i
mean
like how do you do that right um well
good news is
now you know we'll just use regularized
least squares reconstruction
and so for this example um if you have
lambda
equals 10 to the minus 2 that's the
image you get right i
actually all i'm doing here is i'm
taking x-hat um which is this
regularized least squares uh
tomographic reconstruction i take that
and i rearrange it into 100 by 100 thing
and plot it as an image so that's all
these things are and
so i get something like that actually i
mean it's just kind of cool to see you
can do this i mean this is like
you know and now you know what's
involved you stack a couple of matrices
qr factorization done
four lines of code or whatever right so
honestly
your plotting code is going to be longer
for something like this
so now you know real tomographic
reconstruction uses
slightly fancier methods but in
principle this is kind of what they do i
mean this is this is what they do
so um okay here's uh lambda equals 10 to
the minus one and you can see what that
means is it's slightly smoother
if you look you don't see this kind of
speckle it's getting better here's
lambda equals one
five ten and a hundred now i think we
would agree on a couple things first of
all i think that's too little
um that's too little um regularization
because this
this is all that little speckle this
here the image is getting too smoothed
out
so that's probably too much where you
would go in the middle i don't really
know baby five maybe
one um i mean truth is your
best bet in this case would be to figure
out what the application is like for
example
you might be working with radiologists
and then you'd ask radiologists
which which would you like and they
might i don't know they might even
prefer this
and and you'd say why and maybe they
wouldn't know or they would say
something like oh no it's exact you know
uh this one has smoothed out some of
those little dots and some of those
little dots are really important and
i don't know that's what that's that's a
that's the basic idea so
okay so this is um least squares or
i should say regularized least squares
um
used for tomographic reconstruction
and this the idea of tomography comes up
in lots and lots of other areas
i mean a a very interesting one is
i have a colleague who worked on
um tomographic reconstruction of the of
the
transit times um on a subway system
which is kind of cool so what they had
was
uh they don't know how long it takes to
go from this stop to the stop on a
subway
um but what they do have is they have um
sort of like the analog of line
integrals because what they know is a
passenger went into this
subway this station they took this train
transferred then took this train then
transferred took that train and what and
they know when they clocked out at the
other end
so they actually know the sum of three
and if you think careful that's kind of
like a
that's kind of like a line integral it's
this sum of three things
and so basically you have to extract
from
various sums the individual values and
that's the essential idea of
tomography
you